that the gateway class and tickets
to the creation to the existence of a center
for refugees so it is the case to turn
since we have welcomed 6 to the scrapyard is
for the moment more or less 850
refugees therefore applicants for  asylum,
with obviously many young people
of school age in high school, had to
reintegrate into traditional education
each refugee student with a
godfather or godmother in the school
with whom he has privileged contacts,
but it is also outside
from school where they do activities where it
goes well beyond school life
it's a real rigor that this
French peak because it won't it's like
the Italian diego all new suicide
sees it once in  class then
victory parents